لا صوت يعلو فوق دوي المدافع في مخموت
مدينه وصلت القوات الروسيه هجماتها
المكثفه عليها ولم تظهر اي مؤشر على وقف
اقتحامها حسب ما افادت هيئه الاركان
العامه للقوات الاوكرانيه التي اضافت ان
الجيش الاوكراني تمكن من صد الهجمات على
بخموت والمدن المجاوره في وقت يتحدث فيه
القاده العسكريون والسياسيون الاوكرانيون
وفي طليعتهم الرئيس فولوديمير زيلينسكي عن
التمسك بالمواقع واسقاط اكبر عدد ممكن من
الضحايا الروس لتقويض قدرتهم القتاليه
اجتمعت مع الجيش والمخابرات الجبهه
ودفاعنا ومعركه ومخموت
وعمومتنا الاولى
كي نضمن مساهمه خطواتنا التكتيكيه في
المهمه الاستراتيجيه وهي نجاح اوكرانيا في
معركه تحرير كامل اراضي دولتنا المحتله
بشكل مؤقت
مجموعه فاغنر روسيه كانت قد اعلنت استيلاء
مقاتليها على الجزء الشرقي من محمود لكن
الامين العام لحلف الناتو لم يستبعد
احتمال سقوط المدينه بالكامل في ايدي
الروس في الايام المقبله وذلك خلال اجتماع
اتفق فيه وزراء دفاع الاتحاد الاوروبي على
تسريع امداد الجيش الاوكراني بالقذائف
المدفعيه لاجهاض سعي موسكو المحموم
للسيطره على بغمود وان قلل المحللون
الغربيون من القيمه الاستراتيجيه لهذه
المدينه عدا كون الاستيلاء عليها سيعطي
دفعه للرئيس الروسي فلاديمير بوتين وجيشه
بعد سلسله من الانتكاسات في هذه الحرب